fine
I'll do it myself
hey youtubers is Charlie so if you guys
aren't hype already about all the stuff
that's happening next week the Russos
have teased that they're going to be
three post-credit scenes for Captain
America Civil War
that is crazy it's almost like all the
Marvel directors are trying to one-up
each other you did two post-credit
scenes fine
I'm gonna do three and I'm gonna put
spider-man in one of them which i think
is gonna be one of the big possibilities
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
down the list of every single
post-credits scene that Marvel has
already done and then we can theorize
about what these three post-credit
scenes for Civil War are going to be so
refresher here we go Iron Man the very
first Avengers post-credit scene
probably the most surprising one because
people didn't expect that movies would
do stuff like this Tony Stark gets on
board then the Incredible Hulk happens
there's a post-credits scene with
general Thunderbolt Ross and Tony Stark
but it seems like they're working
together and Captain America Civil War
because Thunderbolt Ross is like the
face of the government in this new
organization that they form Iron Man to
Phil Coulson which is still a relatively
small new character finds Thor's hammer
in the desert intro to Thor during which
Loki appears to be a lost but then shows
back up seemingly controlling dr. Selvig
looking at the tesseract big tease or
another tease I should say for The
Avengers movie that we know is coming
they've already announced that Captain
America comes we get another Avengers
post-credit scene when Nick Fury goes to
see Captain America after he's been
unfrozen and says look I'm putting a
team together do you want in finally all
these Hail Mary Avengers post-credit
scenes build into the official Avengers
movie whose post credits scene teases
Thanos so now that they've called their
shot they've done the babe ruth's thing
that says look we are totally doing
Infinity Gauntlet they have to get there
so we get to all the Phase two post
credits scenes which serve a couple
different purposes one is just to
bookend films with funny Avengers
moments in the wake of that film the
others to set up the future solo films
and then the third is to set up the
Avengers sequel so the first post
credits scene of Phase two is Iron Man 3
it doesn't really do much of anything
it's just a book in that film because
they thought it was gonna be the last
Iron Man film at least for a while
Thor the dark world was the first time
that they did two post-credit scenes we
have guardians of the galaxy set up
which was really the big one then we
have another post-credit scene just to
book in and show that Thor is going to
be
staying on earth for the near-term
Captain America Winter Soldier also to
post-credit scenes the first one being
the biggest teasing the twins in the
mind gem the second one was teasing
Bucky just remembering who he is setting
up the next Captain America film and
just to be clear when they filmed Winter
Soldier they did not know that Captain
America 3 would be civil war that only
happened after meetings with Robert
Downey jr. because you can't do civil
war without other Avengers characters
guardians of the galaxy drops also to
post-credit scenes first one teasing
dancing baby Groot from the comics the
second one is largely self-contained but
it's really just teasing Howard the Duck
in all the weird stuff that they didn't
quite fit into the movie not really
meant to set anything up although there
is supposed to be some Howard the Duck
stuff in guardians to so you could kind
of look at it as setup for the second
film but because they didn't know how
Guardians would do they just shot it to
be a little more self-contained they
didn't want it to weave into Avengers or
anything like that we get to the second
Avengers film and there's really only
one post-credit scene it's Thanos saying
that he is going to do it himself then
we have ant-man also to post-credit
scenes one to set up the sequel ant-man
and the wasp into the setup for civil
war with Bucky cap and Falcon I know a
guy really just talking about the
ant-man character and so here we find
ourselves at Civil War so if there's
gonna be three post-credit scenes what
are they well one is probably going to
be to set up that Spider Man film it's
probably part of their sharing
arrangement with Sony that they promote
each other's film if you're already
using someone else's character really
well in a film everyone is super pumped
about their performance the way they
look what's the next best thing you
could do to promote the first film that
he's going to be in by himself well you
could attach a post-credits scene just
to address where things pick up with
that film the second and third will most
definitely be Marvel specific setting up
the future films one will probably be to
set up Doctor Strange because it's such
a weird thing magic is a new thing in
the Marvel Universe they want to give it
as much of a bump as possible so one
very magical Doctor Strange post-credit
scene the other option is that it could
be like a larger Thanos post-credit
scene the Russos and the writers have
said that Thanos is not inside the
actual film Captain America Civil War
they called him magical spaceman and
they're like if we put him in the movie
you would forget instantly what
else was going on you wouldn't remember
anyone's faces all you would be thinking
about is magical spaceman so we won't
see him in an actual film until infinity
war James Gunn has already said that
he's not really in guardians to so if
civil war is the very first film in
phase three they could have a
post-credits scene to throw forward to
the end of phase 3 with infinity war
Thanos but just expect at least one
post-credit scene to directly address
the WTF death that happens in Captain
America Civil War and just remember that
they might have changed what happened
during comic book Civil War they're
doing a lot of things from the comics
but it's not the exact comic book
version of civil war so let me know in
the comments what are your votes for the
three different post credits scenes in
Civil War
probably spider-man maybe infinity war
maybe Doctor Strange so it's gonna
happen next is is there's a new episode
of Walking Dead tomorrow night I'm also
working on a Game of Thrones video I'm
gonna post my next daredevil video on
Monday that'll be episodes 4 through 6
with Easter eggs in case you guys
haven't seen it you can click here for
my first daredevil Easter egg video and
you can click here to learn about the
villains I think are gonna show up in
that first spider-man movie thank you so
much for watching everybody let's have
five I'll see you guys tonight
you